évidemment que la police c'est juste un
révélateur de toutes choses ça que la
police c'est l'étincelle
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure d'été celle
qui fait voilà la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder et donc en fait préféré la
police n'est que le déclencheur d'un
malaise général et des inégalités qui
sont évidemment structurel ou jeu
recueillies dans les quartiers
populaires et plus particulièrement dans
le 93
en seine saint denis donc évidemment que
ce n'est pas que la police évidemment qu
en 2005 c'est la mort de zyed et bouna
mais ce n'est pas que cela c'est tout un
ensemble de choses où on a vu par
exemple des gens qui parlaient
évidemment qui déchirer leur carte
d'identité qui se sentaient pas français
et c'est extra c'est plein de choses qui
font que évidemment que ça que ça
explose quand vous parlez de la
surmortalité aujourd'hui dans le 93
mais évidemment aujourd'hui on a une sur
mentalité parce que quand vous venez de
le dire maintenant on le sait que le
corps n'a du russe est mortel pour les
personnes en surpoids pour des personnes
qui ont des maladies chroniques des
maladies cardiovasculaires évidemment
les questions diabète et quand on
regarde les chiffres et qu'on transpose
des maladies aujourd'hui sur les mare du
canda virus envois que c'est parti c'est
les endroits où il ya le plus de
personnes qui sont atteintes de ces
maladies donc forcément week end est
forcément et moi moi je pense que la
question qu'on doit tous c'est ça
n'explose pas avant de dire qu'en fait
on devrait s'étonner du fait que ce soit
aussi calme en fait parce que quand on
regarde qu'aujourd'hui dans le 93 tu as
donc comme des affaires que ban de l'est
ici on vient complètement rien dans mon
entourage croit j'ai énormément de
personnes que je connais où les parents
sont décédés
un des deux parents qui est décédé dans
mon engagement à titre personnel c'est
énorme en fait ce qui se passe on se
rend pas compte
c'est un peu comme avec la canicule
quand on fera les comptes après et quand
on verra vraiment moi en fait de ce
virus
on en verra qu à l origine sociale et
quelle est l'origine ethnique des
personnes qui sont mortes de ce virus
tiens que aux états unis ont fait
aujourd'hui le comptage ethnique parce
que ces permis aux etats unis c'est les
gars dans bâle iii donc on voit que les
afro-américains sont ceux qui meurent le
plus forcément évidemment c'est la
population le plus d'obèses sa
population ou moins chez le médecin et
cetera et cetera eh ben c'est pareil en
seine saint denis en fait mais sauf
qu'ici voilà jours on a un peu de mal
avec ça ne pas le dire mais en réalité
quand on regarde de plus près les
caissières regard des vigiles dans les
supermarchés etc
ceux qui sont en première ligne ceux qui
travaillent à près d'aix dans les
plateformes de fret etc
ce serait intéressant de regarder leurs
origines sociales et ethniques et en
grec
les deux se croisent et qu'on peut
essayer
[Musique]